and I asked you to do this podcast by
appreciate and you know what after a
while I was like you know what we don't
need them now that you've been on it we
missed you
I'm recording you're on it we may we
missed the magic of Will Sasso on this
podcast and I wish to God that you would
do it again I'll do your podcast again
Bobby and kalila yeah yeah you were so
good
thanks man and we didn't really dive
into a lot no you got good and personal
no we need more personal next time we'll
work into it all right but that way you
you were really amazing thank you so
much for thanks for having me I love you
like your family I like your family and
I'll do it anytime I live just up the
street I'm in Los Feliz I know I've been
to your house it's uh oh you know I ran
to Matt Braunger a while back well I
love Matt and you know we hang out and
stuff but before he I didn't know he was
living in my neighborhood he's not now
but he had this is a dumb story you know
what I'll tell you off the air and your
listeners can be a little upset well not
just kind of makes he just my why don't
you do this you tell this everyone knows
it's a dumb story all right I'll tell
the story it's cap it up but let me say
something right now it's gonna reflect
on you and your abilities but I want you
to do it anyway tell the story now you
have to end up with the story all right
so anyway so my anyway so I run into
Matt around the corner from my house and
he goes yeah I go what do you do you
live here yeah he goes what do you come
by going in like a couple of houses up
on the thing and he goes he goes are you
near Castle Wolfenstein and I said what
and he goes there's a house up there
that looks he goes me and my gal call at
Castle Wolfenstein yeah cuz it looks
like there's a guy up there just
breeding wolves and I go I think I'm dr.
wolf it's that's my house you're
describing yeah because no no it's
[ __ ] thing it looks like Gargamel's
[ __ ] yeah yeah the Smurfs and then he
came over and he was like what the [ __ ]
yeah you live there master Wolfenstein
it's a great you know what I love about
your house oh you came
and go to redfin and find a house like
that that's like there's a it's a
wonderful kind house I bought well the
[ __ ] did you find that castle because it
was 2002 well they make castles this is
[ __ ] the 1700 what you're [ __ ]
talking I know my house was built in
1612 it was the earliest probably in Los
Angeles how did you find it though you
just drove by and go I want to live
there no I went to a different place
no I yeah I actually I jumped out of a
house up the Hollywood Hills cuz I
didn't know where the [ __ ] to live when
I decided to buy a house and they said
and then I had to jump out during escrow
because there was some structural things
I started a new search it was in Los
Feliz I was at this one house they said
have you been by this house no no no and
they told me where I said no and I
walked in there and some some things
happened that were nice like they
dropped the price a lot the morning that
I walked walked in because it was very
it was very ugly there had been there
had been many years of you know
renovations and stuff that reflected the
time period when it was renovated right
so I you know I restored it with a
contractor and designer back to the
original thing that it was but you know
the house was built in the 1930s and and
so that was the thing but it was also
because the market in 2002 was very
different than it was even the next year
in 2003 yeah and so everything exploded
and then we had the you know the
economic collapse of you know 708 so
then you couldn't really get into these
anyways very it's a great house I was
very fortunate I work ready even asked
that's a really good way to you know
what was okay we should ended that yeah
yeah yeah because just like you said you
did some 10-minute podcasts and it
inspired you to move forward yeah
perhaps it even had a guy everyone clap
right now they're not without supper
coming by or not all cut it off they're
not all home run cut it off Eddie
sometimes people just want what Eddie
shows about yeah I met the Osmo
just want to know about the Ontario drop
this weekend you want to hear about rent
a home I'm also pouring here about an
improv I get when you get those pavers
in right and I wanna oh I understand
Brian Ortega for killing [ __ ] keep it
because it will improve the Frankie you
might as well have them come in that
would be a really good I mean I've got
peg and groove hardwood once they
sitting underneath it was centered
underneath marble everybody that was a
great hey claw hammer take it to some of
your right now amazing woods tiger
Vinewood or you can give us any
questions at the tiger belly anything
that you think that someone would take
out and put it in another house that's
what you're looking for in your property
don't be afraid to spend the money
you're living in your investment it make
sure you check out our sponsor Brooklyn
and family it's hard to find a place on
your own sorryi Brooklyn but also
Brooklyn is up there their brother
sponsors women
yeah good to have good linens and they
had a couple and get a get a little
cover for the duvet too just in case
things get saucy with your with your
lady blue apron hey let me tell you
something about blue apron in Los
Angeles people don't necessarily want to
cook all the time you know they want to
go out and eat in restaurant and studies
have shown that it's really great when
you get together with family and you
cook and you have a great time hey blue
aprons got all those ingredients all put
together even if you've got a new
kitchen island you want to put in your
kitchen because you think it'll improve
the resale value of your home it doesn't
matter if you're living in an apartment
or in a studio have your kids over
because you're divorced and cook blue
apron with them hey this month they got
like tilapia chimichangas with with
chimichurri sauce hey I would never
thought to get this stuff there's five
little squash tabs hey what we're doing
the ads for you promo code belly
we'll be right back
we'll be right back after some
housecleaning
[Music]